j'accueille michel serrault
[Applaudissements]
où
michel serrault merci les amis c'est un
triomphe romain domicile 1-0 à massy si
vous faites la même chose qu'en france
et pas la moindre des choses
ben si vraiment c'est bien ils sont bien
vous avez répété à bah oui c'est un vrai
public de télévision c'est un vrai
public de télévision qui réagit au doigt
et à l'oeil regardez par exemple michel
oui
voilà donc même quand c'est pas drôle il
rigole c'est quand même de télévision
c'est par la télévision michel serrault
vous dites j'ai longtemps joué le jeu
parce que c'est vrai que quand j'étais
jeune je voulais devenir clown mais à
présent la télé ça m'ennuie normaux ça
m'ennuie pas d'accord non non non je
m'ennuie pas pour y être là pour moi en
même temps obama patients nuno les
confidences et des je suis un peu là
pour toi même j'essaie michel nom vous
dit on parle la télévision il ya des
soirées entières qui sont faites en
repiquant des débats ce qui est ici
c'est à dire que j'ai pas me déplacer
il ya des réserves terrible alors je
revois des trucs non parce que c'est
amusant parce qu'on fait des choses par
exemple c'est vrai que j'ai montré mes
fesses il ya quelques temps dans un
journal télévisé français c'était un
grand moment
mais c'était pour une fois oui mais
alors là c'est tous les quinze jours
alors qu'ils le fassent
je sais que belle fête mais quand même
bien alors vous êtes ici pour la sortie
d'un film qui s'appelle une hirondelle a
fait le printemps de christian carion
avec mathilde seigner qui sort le 5
septembre
vous savez faire les petites mains s'il
vous plaît allez-y
bien alors c'est un film très étonnant
parce que c'est un film sans famille
recomposée 100/100 homosexualité sans
drogue qui se passe à la campagne c'est
un film très très inattendu c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune femme qui jouait
par mathilde seigner qui joue le rôle
qui a 30 ans qui est informaticienne à
paris et qui laisse tomber son boulot
d'informaticienne pour devenir
agricultrice et on voit d'ailleurs
l'agriculture d'une façon très réaliste
c'est pas du tout du colis qu'on
s'aperçoit que c'est un métier
extrêmement difficile quand on voit le
film donc elle part dans une ferme
isolée dans le dans le vercors il
débarque chez vous qui êtes là tout seul
dans cette ferme
votre femme est décédée il ya quelques
quelques années vous êtes tout seul
voyais très peu de très peu de gens
faisaient pas très copain avec avec les
autres agriculteurs delà de la région
sauf un qui est joué d'ailleurs par jean
paul roussillon s'est tellement bien
dans le film quand je l' ai vu je me
suis dit puisque je me souvenais pas du
tout de jean paul roussillon comme ça
quand j'ai vu le film je me suis dit
mais c'est incroyable on trouvait un
paysan qui joue vachement bien alors
vous donc vous êtes là dans cette ferme
tout seul voulait la vendre en fait
cette ferme vous les voulez partir pour
allez vous installer près de près de
grenoble
et puis cette fille arrive ne vous êtes
pas décidé à aller des 1
vous n'êtes pas très sympa il faut dire
aussi que le fermier en question à de
graves problèmes bull pas là
et a eu la vache folle lui a battu son
troupeau on est abattu son troupeau
il a perdu sa famille les liens un
contexte terrible il faut dire aussi
qu'il a pas 20 ans parce que c'est joué
par un acteur cap à 20 ans non plus oui
je veux dire que c'est pas une fin de
vie mais enfin c'est une famille est
beaucoup plus vieux dans le film que
vous ce soir là je vous le dis quand
même installé des barrages
bah c'est un rôle de composition oui ça
se voit là il s'agit je ne suis pas
vraiment un pays dont on a remué quoique
encore que oui alors comment centre
entre mathilde seigner vous donc une
espèce de dan et de cohabitation puisse
quitter sa terre dans un monde a fermé
il ya quelque chose qui va pas ils
écoutent leur fait sceptique quand ils
voient arriver cette île a décidé de
vendre il le dit d'ailleurs à son copain
une main je vends j'en ai eu marre c'est
fini et c est quand il voit arriver la
jeune le jeune personne il est sceptique
1 et elle vient de la ville alors les
gens de la ville et de la campagne il
faut il faut qu'il faut un moment pour
que ça ça fonctionne et alors ça va être
la rencontre et voilà ouais et il passe
un an comme ça se côtoyer dans cette
ferme sans vraiment se parlait elle elle
monte un gîte rural
elle a une vision très moderne de
l'agriculture elle vend ses fromages sur
internet aux allemands et lui vous vous
regardez cela donne à ses petits tout ça
pour garder sa dernière un peu un peu
quantitatif un symbole film regard
kadhafi qui piaffent d'impatience si
vous adore baffie il veut absolument
être là quand vous allez laurent il
s'est caché alors d'un fils
lamy
non
non ma fille je veux bien faire ce
métier ouais quand elle avec l'intérêt
des gens comme michel rétrécir je vais
pas été vous voir mais je sais que vous
triomphez invite rihaoui
ils sont partis pour un an c'est vrai
public parce que il faut pas il faut
assister quand ça fonctionne dans le
temps j'ai joué une pièce pendant deux
trois ans c'était un peu comique
enfin un rôle de composition n'attendez
pas bien alors on ressent en regardant
le film comme ça que vous avez envie
d'inventer sans arrêt il est toujours
prêt à jouer dès très très enfantin
finalement vous ajouter sans arrêt une
dimension créative au personnage mais je
pense qu'il faut penser il faut lire
mais je crois que sur le au moment où on
tourne il faut inventer
ouais il faut inventer quelque chose
pour ça que ça m'amuse toujours quand on
ya pas très longtemps à un auteur très
connu avec beaucoup de talent au qui me
voyaient tourné plusieurs reprises et
musique vous en effet une deux trois ans
on fait le 3 400 une suprise il dit
c'est rigolo parce qu' elle ne s'est
jamais la même julie sont en fait 6 par
la phase 6 mais je pense qu'à chaque
fois on on peut inventer quelque chose
aux données des nuances différentes
il faut soigner au cinéma il faut jouer
faut pas jouer avant oui faut pas jouer
après ça il faut être bon pendant moteur
michel serrault quand vous étiez enfant
vous hésitiez entrée de clown est prêtre
et si vous étiez au petit séminaire
et puis un jour au petit séminaire vous
a fait comprendre que vous étiez plus
fait pour les planches superbes et vous
seriez peut-être mieux sur les planches
vous aime bien mais voilà alors suis
parti ouais et puis j'étais sur les
planches et vos premiers établissements
c'était les clowns la première fois que
vous avez parce que quand j'étais gosse
je tape j'habitais la banlieue est
évidemment je n'allais pas à la comédie
française tous les soirs
les premiers spectacles que j'ai vu
c'est le cirque ouais le cirque et je
conseillerais malheureusement voit plus
beaucoup le cirque comme autrefois et on
voit plus de grands clowns ça n'existe
plus parce que ce qui est formidable
c'est de les clones n'existe que et ne
sont possibles que dans l' architecture
du cirque sur une piste et il ya eu les
informations il ya une musique colza
était fini ils ont disparu
ils étaient ils étaient là pour le rond
et pour ça alors et j'ai eu la chance de
voir ça me rajeunit pas mais les plus
grandes plaines du skate
j'ai vu les trois fratellini je serai
très fier françois albert épaules et je
vais parler avec albert qui était
l'auguste le plus outré du cirque
c'était surréaliste d'ailleurs c'était à
l'époque en mines
il a été débordé tim moss dans les
années 30 et il m'a dit il était très
triste il m'a dit vous comprenez a pas
mais mon cher ami avec l'accent italien
que je ne sais pas pas de me dis ils
sont terribles a paris il ya beaucoup de
cercles ils font tous ils ont les mêmes
cheveux - avec des perruques qui tourne
avec un nez rouge
ils savent pas que c'est pas ça qui fait
rien je fais rire avec ça il m'a montré
sa poitrine et c'est l'émotion intérieur
la présence intérieure tant qu'un acteur
pose que celles extérieures qui compte
il est foutu c'est pas la peine
alors vous dites clown c'est comme
prédicateurs finalement il faut donner
de soi en étant conscient que l'on tient
les manettes
finalement c'est un peu le même métier
que vous faites finalement vous n'avez
pas choisi entre cloud des prêtres je
veux dire qu'on ne peut pas il faut
insérer de tricher et de truquer un
acteur doit pas truqué il faut moi ça
m'arrive je suis pris à mon propre jeu
mais quand même on tient les ficelles de
la marionnette qu'on est à ce moment là
ray alors le gars qui dit moi je perd
conscience je ne suis plus où je suis je
suis pas d'accord j'y croyais pas je
crois que je pense qu'on doit se diriger
art absolument absolument
alors donc ça n'a pas marché au petit
séminaire comme on l'a dit et puis vous
avez été refusée au conservatoire va
marcher mais après deux ans d'études
blanche et que vous avez rencontré
poiret ça s'est passé comment c'était en
52 vous étiez au on était des comédiens
refusé au conservatoire de vous lier des
comédiens classique quand même oui et
enfin et ça se voit pas si si j'ai joué
laver les deux avaient été refusées
comme bartoli des il dit
on s'est aperçu qu'on rie et des même
chose quand vous après ça vous savez
c'est capital
on peut pas être porteur d'un certain
esprit d'un certain humour si on le
comprend pas et si on s'amuse pas avec
ses plans possibles
donc on voit ça c'est une chance
formidable à vos débuts avec jean poiret
finalement c'était l'époque des cabarets
le tabou l'olympia bobino l'alhambra
tout ça oui c'est à dire qu'on a on
s'est rencontré à lyon parce qu'on
faisait des petits métiers des petites
choses et ont joué jeudi matin aux
besoins des matinées classiques au
théâtre sarah bernhardt et on serait ya
tellement en inventant des choses il me
dit il on devrait faire un bon mais pour
gagner sa vie c'est le hasard et la
nécessité je sais pas pour à croire
qu'on a évité on va monter un numéro et
on a monté un numéro
c'est le côté du eux aussi avaient roger
pierre et jean marc thibault da racing a
tué avant nous et devos après nous mais
mais nous est alors on se voyait tous
les jours de 12 heures à 6 heures
lui jouait déjà la revue aux deux ânes
et moi chez déry et l'allant kenyon les
branquignols et à la tomate avec roccat
kaka était un homme formidable d'un
local où on a travaillé pour lui c'était
des moments inoubliables
voilà vous êtes devenu clown plutôt
prêtre employeur d'une certaine façon
mais vous êtes quand même resté très
croyant et vous dites on a du mal à
accepter que zaza napoli
le lendemain matin soit la messe à 9
heures je vois pas pourquoi ça gêne la
police n'aurait pas versé en over façon
moi ça ne me gêne pas quelques fois on
me rappelle alors dire des gens qui me
disent mais comment on pourrait avoir
les idées que vous avez en même temps
jouer le miraculé oui mais je dis allez
donc faire un tour à lourdes où vous
verrez les marchands du temple comment
ça se passe vous êtes très croyants de
la présence de dieu est là les
situations les plus dramatiques peuvent
être sublime et avec amour et partage ja
vous avez perdu une fille où il ya des
gens pour qui un gros malheurs comme ça
fait perdre la foi vous comment vous
êtes arrivé à garder votre foi
chrétienne malgré cette souffrance et
malgré cette tragédie
j'ai la foi mais je ne comprends pas
tout j'ai la foi je sais très bien ce
qui se passe dans le monde
je sais qu'il ya des enfants qui meurent
guen la justice qu'il ya enfin veut pas
avoir à compter vous vers le journal
télévisé en grèce en prison en montant
mais n'empêche qu'il ya une part de
responsabilité des hommes quand même
quelque part
et ma foi n'est pas
je crois en dieu si vous voulez c'est
vrai et bien de temps en temps je
m'écroule et jeudi je ne comprends pas
un dieu je te comprends pas mais ça vous
empêche pas d'y croire non demandez aux
gens ici s'ils savent comment marche la
télévision soit bien embêté demi dieu je
sais pas comment une main encore mais ça
n'empêche pas de la voir et puis bon je
vais pas pressé je veux pas faire une
prédication
mais je veux dire c'est qu'il ya dieu et
puis à jésus-christ jésus christ nous a
laissé assez de repère pour essayer de
vivre comme il a enseigné et basta le
reste vous savez c'est trop facile de le
dire mais c'est trop compliqué je fait
un pas en avant
c'est déjà pas mal alors il ya un truc
que j'ai jamais eu si l'audience papale
et pourtant c'était votre rêve et quand
vous dit exit hier comme vous étiez à
rome pour jouer la cage aux folles de
oui le producteur vous dis moi je
connais bien le pape je vais te trouver
une audience et c est en fait vous dont
vous mais vous quittez votre costume de
zaza napoli vous mettez un costume bleu
marine une cravate
vous y allez et vous découvrez qu'en
fait c'était pas une audience privée
c'est une audience publique
les audiences publiques ont été saccagés
c'était c'était la récompense du pauvre
enfant j'étais très drôle
alors on va faire une hardy view
attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
vous avez bougé par l'ingénieur michel
sais pas je sais pas ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait des bêtises
c'est à dire que d'habitude c'est ma
fille qui bouge là je le trouve
particulier il a été très sage et très
bien par arriver à côté de mes bêtises
j'ai bu vos paroles je n'ai pas écouté
alors attention ne bouge pas par ici on
bouge michels et des clubs en me
couchant
non c'est comme ça attention les gars
font piéger bien on connaît les
muscadets jeu c'est des conneries faut
pas l'écouter en ébauchant on est moche
bonjour
king
[Musique]
c'est mitigé non mais là il n'y a pas
franchement une folie batista invente
alors bougez michel michel pouey bouger
là
non pas bien gros michael alors
attention première question maintenant
on va pas déconner trop ah non non non
attention vous seront incompatibles avec
mal ce que je viens de dire bien entendu
mais maintenant vous avez une grande can
oui mon frère vous êtes blagueur et
mystique des sculptures ou si vous êtes
blagueur et mystique
c'est incompatible tous croient non
justement c'est bien quand on retrouve
ces deux qualités chez la même personne
trouve ça bien à moi je mêle d'ailleurs
je vais à l'église pour rire et au
théâtre pour pleurer
michel serrault quand vous vous regardez
le matin dans la glace vous vous dites
quoi
j'ai un peu vieilli n'a peu vieilli le
tout c'est tout con du montage non 108
ah oui savait pas quand avez vous pleuré
pour la dernière fois
écoutez je vais vous faire une
confidence parce que oui il n'y a pas
souvent 20 jeux je ris comme je pleurais
je ris comme france gall et il sait bien
parce que le gars qui sait pas pleurer
et bien ne sais pas rires
et l'inversé vrai fontenelle disais tout
ce que je ne peux pas toucher tout ce
que je ne peux pas comprendre tout ce
que ma tête ma raison ou nation ne peut
pas définir où trouver ça n'existe pas
bah dis donc ça n'existerait alors je
j'ai pleuré quand j'ai vu main et quand
il dit à la fin sur son lit là un mot
formidable souffle il dit ce sont des
soupirs il dit je me regrette 1 1 c'est
beau alors tu achètes pas vous regrettez
que j'installe profiter et mais moi je
dis aux gens aimés et mais n'importe
quoi et mails pinet arrêt mais parce
qu'on commence par le pinard et puis
vous allez monter des escaliers bien
c'est vrai un homme une femme des
enfants et vieillards
vous aimerez faire plaisir vous aimerez
un tas de choses mais mettez en route ce
qu'on a là qu'ils appellent le coeur et
vous savez que le coeur il est fait pour
battre alors ayez ce sentiment d'amour
de temps en temps aimer c'est drôle je
n'entends pas qui va essayer de faire
battre votre coeur du temps
vous devez faire une annonce je
souhaitais enchères à l'homme notre dame
et si l'équipe cherry currie comme bourg
était plus de monde dans les églises
vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique de je crois
que je changerais rien moi on peut pas
changer
non il faut assumer ce qu'on aime faire
ce que le pardon que j'ai une bosse sur
le nez parce que c'était bon c'est
arrivé comme ça je veux dire c'est un
homme timide à un ennui de santé etc
je me regarde je dis la écoute qu'il ya
plus grave
il ya par exemple il faut parfois faux
pas peut-être que ça c'est l'assaut
peut-être que si je suis bien dans le
film
dans ce pays' ans est très compatible
ray donc merci mon dieu d'avoir une
bonne suée mais non faut pas recommencer
c'est vous qui avez vous le plus envie
d'épater par le nerf à part le nez avec
le nez c'est fait je me sens et une
confidence n'écoutait pas moi oui vous
aurez m'épater mai mais s'est arrêté
quand même jamais ne voudrait refaire
beaucoup de choses là oui mais on
voudrait si jamais fini il mettrait
acteurs alors bon bah je voudrais aussi
alors qu'est ce que je voudrais faire
je voudrais continuer ma en face comme
au théâtre je voudrais jouer tous les
jours
c'est ça la force du théâtre soit on 0
par la bafi commun c'est bien le jour il
est où il a été magnifique effet que le
lendemain il est revenu puis il a joué
depuis dix ans émis avant-hier les
circuits se dit il vit vous allez voir
lui même me dit vous allez voir un prêt
demain j'arrête la bonne ou jeu serait
formidable
au cinéma c'est fait s'est figé qu'il
faut j'aimerais revenir sur la question
car il n'y a pas des fois où vous
regardez sur l'écran il n'apparaît pas
où vous êtes et pathé vous n'êtes pas
impactés
j'ai revu parce que j'ai droit à la cage
aux folles tous les ans général ma femme
me dit il ya la cage la horde une au
coach ça va je connais et puis su rester
je vais vous écouter de la musique ou
lire je m'en vais
et puis j'ai vu le générique j'étais
debout là derrière le fauteuil me suis
assis je ne devrais pas le dire mais
j'ai riches l'année 2009
viry sa demande des explications si
calculons il ferait bien sûr ça oui et
dans les trois segments
c'est un peu inégal il ya des borgia bon
c'est vrai bon ne peut pas être pas ça
peut pas être parfait partout mais même
dans la dernière case avec galabru quand
je suis dans le gâteau j'étais par terre
dans mon salon je dis qu'ils sont
gonflés quand même ces deux acteurs là
alors attention quand le téléphone sonne
vous êtes heureux ou agacés jeu c'est à
dire juste heureux parce que quand ça ne
sonne pas c'est un peu malheureux là et
quand ça sonne tous obligés de décrocher
quel est le con qui m'appelle malades
donc c'est tout le temps et ça vous
énerve tout ça on est tous comme ça
qu'elle est la dernière chose que vous
faites avant de vous coucher
je fais ma prière j'ai un moment d'arrêt
ouais je fais ma prière
alors allez un peu bizarroïdes ray je
demande un tas de choses bougent
demandeur rien enfin un constat est une
espèce d'examen de conscience avant de
vous coucher c'est pas de tiamat
constant vu comment ça s'est passé
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt à la baisse ou
à la hausse ou ses plats où on peut être
aussi un peu découragé où on dit on y en
a marre
qu'est ce que tu peux faire leur débit
non ouais mais il faut faire attention
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai j'ai un poste
où j'ai indiqué coutteure puis je me dis
quoi
allez une cantate de bach ça peut pas me
faire et je m'endors dans l'art devient
de mozart ou de bas rhin
essayez ça essayez vous verrez que les
petits soucis disparaissent faut pas
avoir peur
le
essai
michel serrault dernière question de
quelle question aimeriez vous avoir la
réponse
je voudrais savoir pourquoi je suis dans
le dans le lot pourquoi nous pensons
toujours à nous voilà nous pourquoi je
pense à moi pourquoi tu pense à toi
pourquoi tu penses à 3 pourquoi c'est
normal de penser à soi mais je lui
reconnais un peu de de présence pour les
autres voilà et comment ça se fait qu'on
est tous les uns et les autres replier
sur nous-mêmes et qu'on a finalement on
a peur de l'autre et michel pendant vos
quêtes croyant est ce que vous pensez
que vous allez reformer un jour le duo
poiret serrault
oui mais du nul
je pense que quand je joue la comédie
bien souvent je pense à jean et quand
pour moi le cdc des vacances sur terre
encore je pense que pour un tas de gens
mais je des retrouvailles
l'incurie mattler notre premier invité
monsieur michel serrault
[Applaudissements]
oui
g
alors michel
soit
voilà
je vous demande de vous arrêter
[Applaudissements]
être avec nous pour cette dernière
émission de l'année 2001 tu n'es pas de
smoking gun tapas suis toujours à
billère lardy sombre et je ne veux pas
me fâcher
ouais je voudrais que tu te mettes en
smoking
[Applaudissements]
bobbie goulding demande de vous arrêter
à
parce que j'y vais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la dernière fois que j'ai mis un collier
de chien c'était avec di falco il en
place quand on ne pas fillon ça va voilà
nos vies et bien non
la jeune classe merci michel serrault
est ce que je peux demander sa la pa
semi enterré un minimum et un peu de
respect pour le nettoie en slip au prix
de la redevance
on relève le nom et des piles et vous
savez c'est l'ange blanc qui va le faire
l'ange blanc s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
georges blanc qu'est-ce qu'il est beau
mélange mans alors donc ce bouquin wii
commence par l'énoncé de votre
philosophie
à l'époque vous jouiez knock au théâtre
et puis y avait des gens qui veulent
voir dans la loge comme ils vont voir
leur ont d'ailleurs tous les soirs pour
le féliciter
il ya une dame qui vient et qui vous dit
excusez moi de vous dire ça monsieur
zéro mais vous vous il ya une dame qui
vient et qui vous dit dan qui bégayait
mais c'est lui qui doit le dire c'est sa
chute elle a dit quoi cette dame alors
une dame qui vient vous voir donc et qui
vous dit excusez moi monsieur zéro mais
vous m'avez tellement fait rire et vous
lui répondez que vous excusez pas madame
je les fais exprès là est toute la
philosophie de michel serrault et
contenus dans cette réplique d'une
certaine façon
alors dans ce genre de réflexion ce que
j'ai lu dans votre bouquin c'est qu'à
l'époque où vous jouiez la cage aux
folles
il ya il ya une dame qui a dit quand
même pour ce rôle il aurait quand même
pu trouver une femme oui ben voilà
comment ça s'est passé est un formidable
on allait boire un verre à la fin du
spectacle juste en face au palais royal
et il y avait là il y avait deux couples
et les gens étaient ravis de la soirée
alors ils étaient là moi j'étais
démaquiller et puis de la voiture yeux
j'étais bon
elle me connaissait pas et j'entendais
les commentaires sur le spectacle et son
formidable homme alors surtout bateau
monsieur pour arrêt et l'autre belle
soeur qui m'écoutent germaine ya une
chose que je comprends pas mais il y
avait bien apparaît une comédienne pour
jouer le rôle de monsieur c alors au
début du livre vous parlez de votre
enfance on a déjà raconté ici en moi
j'ai appris des détails
c'est tellement loin maintenant mon doux
et gentil alors après vous parlez de
votre maître dans l'art dramatique jean
le goff jean le coffre qui fuse a appris
le boulot quoi ils disaient ou aux
acteurs aux jeunes acteurs écoute c'est
une écoute pas te peux pas répondre
ça va de soi écoute ton partenaire
regarde le soit vraiment avec lui est
une chose essentielle quand on joue la
comédie et respire ouais mais respirent
la respiration de l'auteur c'est à dire
que le si vous ne trouvez pas la cadence
et la respiration de dans molière dans
l'art pago dans tous les maliens et bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe
et bien l'acteur va disparaître
asphyxiés il va s'étouffer des décors
sont de roger à des costumes
donald cardwell ça fait trois très
jeunes tous et à tous les cas michel
faisait toujours une photo dédicacée de
jean le goff menace de vous chez vous où
est écrit à michel serrault qui sera un
grand pitre et ce qui pourrait être pris
comme quelque chose de péjoratif pour
vous c'est toujours été un grand
compliment ce qu'il compte les mots
comptent dans la quand on joue la
comédie le texte compte énormément
mais c'est les intentions si tu dis à
quelqu'un à lui fait un titre très bien
ouais mais lui il a un teint grand pitre
ouais magnifique
tout est dans l'intention alors vous
raconter et dans ce livre enfin votre
rencontre avec jean poiret c'était
devant le théâtre sarah bernhardt vous
il a que tous les deux pour un rôle et
puis lui vous dis comme ça vous
connaissiez pas le bigoudi de toute
façon je suis sûr d'être engagé j'ai une
fortune personnelle et vous visiterez
comme moi ma mère connaît la cousine du
concierge et on a beau dire le piston
sajoo oui c'est sûr mais là vous êtes
trouvé sur ces deux répliques pleines de
non sens tu sais les rencontres c'est le
hasard et la nécessité
on avait beaucoup de mal à jouer la
comédie on avait 22 ans quelque chose
qui est là et c'était pas les jeunes
premiers il y avait toujours les jeunes
premiers au théâtre avait une 40 ou 45
ans elle part ça a changé un peu mais on
avait des difficultés la seule façon de
gagner sa vie c'était d'aller au cabaret
alors vous vous rencontrez dans devant
le théâtre sarah bernhardt ces deux
répliques évidemment vous vous vous
réunissez et une amitié qu'il y aura 40
ans
et un jour et un jour jean poiret vous
dis tu veux pas qu'on essaye de monter
un truc tous les deux et là votre
première source d'inspiration a été la
télévision et pourtant à l'époque la
télévision
pas beaucoup de postes étaient 53 oui et
déjà la vacuité des interviews
télévisées
c'est déjà assez grave à l'époque
apparemment et vous créer un personnage
qui s'appelle jerry scott vedettes
internationales
c'était qui c'était un acteur français
parce que pour les gens c'est par un
acteur français mais euh disons que
c'est ce qu'on entendait un peu partout
dans les commentaires pour être un grand
acteur il fallait passer de toute façon
par l'amérique oui il y en ait pas
d'acteurs français à la hauteur des
américains donc nous on avait fait un
personnage qui était france a été ramené
en auvergne où quelque part c'était il
ya 17 août sa carrière en amérique et
revenaient un jour dire bonjour à la
france et c'était ringard
ouais vous fait vos débuts au tabou dans
un club de jazz rue dauphine le 11
janvier 53 à l'annonce de poids est
incroyable vous allez voir une énorme
vedette internationale etc
et là vous arrivez vous dans votre
costume gris un peu comme un comme un
guichetier de banque sans sourire et ils
vous interviews et on découvre vous
effet cinq films à hollywood
richelieu richelieu à richelieu et
d'étudiants de tourner toute une série
y'avait riche que chez les nazis et
frankenstein mais alors là c'est
incroyable donc en une nuit venez star
tous les deux un papier de max favalelli
et commence le marathon des cabarets
c'est à dire vous faites la tomate à 22
heures chez gilles à 00h30 le tabou à 2
heures le sketch comme ça vous juillet
dans la nuit dans les rangs parce qu'il
fallait faire pourrait pas passer le
même sketch hilarant avec à tout ce
bruit avec quatre choses différé ça il y
avait donc clément laprade explorateurs
donc en là vous arriviez
dit j'ai du retard des trois fois mon
départ alors ils disaient pourquoi vous
avez des difficultés pour réunir le
matériel et vous répondiez non pleyel
n'était pas libre c'est charest y avait
un sketch aussi c'était stéphane bras
vil prix visionnaire oui ça tout le
monde y passe et c'était toujours au
départ c'est toujours des interviews qui
avait collecté ce que vous écrivez à
cette époque là je balayais la cour
dubaï et la cour la cour était way est
bien mais à un moment aussi où il disait
en pleine occupation vous et quand même
soutenu que shakespeare était allemand
oui alors vous répondez enfin jusqu'à
fin 44
on y reconnaît plus belle et le fameux
sketch des antiquaires ah oui donc un
couple d'homosexuels 15 ans avant la
cage aux folles dans ses parodies d'une
interview comme ça oui parce que nos
femmes et aimait beaucoup les
antiquaires est vrai c'est beaucoup
d'endroits et on connaît on avait des
amis qui tient des boutiques
extraordinaire et on a fait avec jean on
a fait un truc folie ouais ils voulaient
me vendre
j'ai vu une dame qui rentrait dans la
boutique qui est finalement elle va le
trouver pour ce qu'elle voulait il usé
mes joues devant lui il me sert à quoi
il sert à rien et qu'elle pose et
lorsqu'à incroyable michel serrault si
vous avez fait donc les antiquaires 15
ans avant la cage aux folles et pareil
pour vos rôles sérieux c'est à dire qu'à
l'âge de 26 ans vous tournez les
diaboliques de clouzot film vous êtes un
personnage assez sérieux il a fallu
attendre des années après avant vous
fassiez l'argent des autres gardes à vue
ou le docteur petiot
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire ça veut
dire que les gens n'ont pas vraiment les
gens on est souvent les acteurs pierre
quand on avait aussi eu un parcours un
peu bizarroïdes
bon j'ai voulu être clown j'ai voulu on
a fait du music hall on a écrit des
sketches
on a joué au théâtre et cetera où on
n'était pas des gens très sérieux coup à
faire
on n'était pas des vrais acteurs et puis
un jour j'étais à la tomate c'est que
nous on est venu me voir et me dit voilà
mon cher ami je connais un peu avec le
genre littéraire
si vous vouliez tourner dans mon si vous
voulez bien de moi puis voilà
et puis voilà un soir de novembre 67
effectivement gens et vous allez voir
l'escalier donc avec paul meurisse et
daniel ivernel à la comédie des champs
elysées donc c'est l'histoire la pièce
l'escalier c'est l'histoire de deux
vieux homos qui s'envoient des vacheries
à la gueule toute la soirée et il vous
dit pourquoi on fait pas une pièce mais
comique dans le style des antiquaires
alors ce qui est extraordinaire ce que
j'ai appris en lisant votre bouquin
c'est qu'au départ pendant vous répétiez
la pièce il y avait une mauvaise rumeur
dans paris c'est à dire que les
homosexuels penser que c'est une pièce
pursuit de leur gueule un peu
ouais un peu alors comme ben vous allez
on répète un mois mois et demi tous ept
et est clandestin quand on répète une
pièce en général on la montre pas tout
de suite
ouais et c'est donc le bruit courait
qu'on allait faire des choses un petit
peu agressive et caetera et au départ
c'était un peu difficile mais je sais
que dans certains restaurants je veux
dire poiret serrault n'étaient pas les
bienvenus ouais et puis alors après
miracle du théâtre est enfin ceci étant
comme jacques charon mais l'énorme
comédien il n'est pas venu tout de suite
il a mis trois cages et moi avons gagné
trois ou quatre ou six mois après alors
la cage aux folles et célèbre parce que
c'était à durée variable quoi se dire
qu'il ya des soirs de certaines scènes
qui pouvait faire cinq minutes et
d'autres soir 15 manor ont raconté
sylvain que entre la plus la séance la
représentation la plus courte et la plus
longue
il y avait une heure de différence bon
c'était pas tous les jours mais c'est
parce que il y avait des improvisations
ça a duré donc ça a duré cinq ans vous
l'avais joué 15 cents fois sans
lassitude au chant lassitude j'avais le
mystère du théâtre c'est que je sais
jamais moi je vous dis pas que je secret
quelconque je ne sais jamais comment ça
va se passer quand je jouais repas
gauche disait je ne sais pas si je vais
partir avec ma car je ne savais pas je
me mets sur le rail de du de l'auteur et
puis peut-être qu'il va y avoir quelque
chose d'un accident quelqu'un qui va se
lever dans la salle du gars mais vous en
faites pas vos gros ce sont des gens des
abrutis gardez vos sous
vous emmerdez pas par exemple du bas
vous avez raison et ce soir
parallèlement à ma cassette je suis très
heureux jean on ne sait pas ce qui peut
arriver
l'acteur qui sait ce qui va arriver les
foutus il faut pas savoir comment ça se
passe je ne sais pas et quand on joue la
page
on savait pas comment ça allait finir
peut-être call soir je serai partie par
là dans la salle en disant tu m'emmerdes
et cetera
il y avait il faut décès cette porte
ouverte à l'invention ça c'est que c'est
essentiel alors la cage aux folles n'a
jamais été enregistré par la télévision
et le cinéma ni quatre ans c'est même
pas des français les italiens c'est
marcello et parce qu'il est l'éléphant
les français sont toujours sont toujours
des gens avertis de près et connaissent
tout généralement et les imbéciles qui
avait à ce moment là il n'a toujours des
cons mais les imbéciles du cinéma me
disait tu comprends bien vous comprenez
bien que ce qui fait rire spécialistes
producteurs
des sous pour aider vous pensez bien
moins vite que ce qui fait rire au
théâtre ne peut pas amuser les gens au
cinéma il avait oublié que toutes les
grandes comédies américaines
c'était du théâtre c'est et du theater
départ alors il a fallu un autre ami à
nous que tu es moins bête peut-être
qu'ils étaient italiens qui a dit moi
j'ai vu la cage dix fois ça me fait rire
autant et jean faire un film et voilà et
puis les français
alors comme il était italien et l'a pris
au togo nassau
il a été très mal en toc n'a ainsi pas
ce qu'il s'est pas mis en rivalité avec
vous c'est à dire qu'il vous allez c'est
vraiment sur le devant la chapeau mais
je pense que c'est comme ça qu'il faut
faire son métier
il a été d'une parce que vous avez
canton il ya deux comiques ensemble il
n'ya qui se prend pas le clown l'auguste
et l'autre pour le coup nous blanc et
puis dans la travaille dans la tête des
gens il y en a qui se dit mois sous le
faire valoir et c'est l'autre qui fait
rire avec poiret je pense que jamais ça
existe et ça c'est dit c'est pas des
choses à dire c'est pas des choses à
faire c'est pas digne de ce métier ce
qui est intéressant c'est ce qui se
passe entre poiret et serrault prêt si
ce qui se passe entre tonia dit et je
dois dire que chapeau parce que
quelqu'un que je mets beaucoup qui était
un inventeur formidable un improvisateur
extraordinaire qu avait du charme et a
été dans le il ne savait que l'eau il ya
forcément dans des pièces d'aider des
rôles qui sont plus efficaces
il le savait mais il a été parfait
parfait
chapeau alors vous parlez dans votre
bouquin de l'accident qui a coûté la vie
à votre fille caroline à l'âge de 19 ans
vous dites que cela vous a rapproché de
michel audiard qui avait connu le riz le
même malheur et c'est extraordinaire
dans ce bouquin enfin une des choses
extraordinaires dans ce bouquin c'est
que tous les soirs vous alliez jouer la
case vous jouiez vous fait rire les gens
écoutent et en sortant vous écroulez
dans les bras d'un régisseur pour
pleurer c'est extraordinaire ça se
trouve écoutez moi s'il ya une chose que
je voudrais
faire comprendre c'est que je suis comme
les autres disons que j'ai quelqu'un
pourrait peut-être pas faire ça oui non
mais je veux dire ils peuvent souffrir
les autres peuvent souffrir mais peuvent
peut-être à l'armée lambie aplon disais
que j'ai nommé dans tout dans tous les
métiers ça peut te le chef de gare le
flic qui guèye qui perd sa fille le le
paysan il a les mêmes ccga le même
problème c'est le même peine mais c'est
la même peine mais vous vous étiez autre
théâtre et vous faisait rire les gens et
et c'est incroyable pour pour nous c'est
avoir plus incroyables laurence et que
l'après midi vous jouiez offenbach pour
la télé achat chez plus grave est qu un
jour il ya eu la première scène à
tournai et c'était un enterrement et à
ce moment là
michel boiron vient vous voir et et vous
dit michel si vous voulez renoncer
franchement je comprendrais dima dima
dit michel
il m'a dit on tourne à une autre fois en
jus d'union alors là
je ne sais pas moi qui suis là c'est le
personnage la wii et ne pas le jouer
n'enlève rien à la peine ce qui est vrai
en même temps oui j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un je dirait pas son nom mais un
ami à moi qui me dit peut-être que mon
métier ma m'a aidé et m'a aidé et m'a
aidé parce que
j'étais obligé de fournir et de jouer
donc celui qui veut pas impressioner de
métro n'a peut-être pas ses sources
ouais alors ne nous plaignons pas ce
comme les autres mais par bonheur
peut-être que mon métier m'a aidé alors
dis toi michel serrault c'est vrai que
emmanuel avait séché les séances de
lecture commune pendant la préparation
du film avec claude sautet a dit sur un
ton livre non mais étant donné que j'ai
dit je les peaux tête écrit ouais j'ai
dit non non plus avec claude sautet
c'était absolument impossible de sécher
quoi que ce soit tu t'en souviens 10 et
enfin je la connais c'est pas la peine
qu'elles viennent aux séances de lecture
parce que je la connais il avait alors
sauté en fait sauter vous avez vu dans
la cage aux folles
il était assez sceptique sur le fait de
vous engager dans le rôle de monsieur
arnaud et puis un jour il va vous voir
dans knock est effectivement et c'est
cette fameuse phrase qu'a donné le titre
du livre évidemment vous avez dix héros
et wiba serreau finalement il a été
d'accord pour vous prendre
vous aussi vous êtes sceptique avant de
faire deux films non en mode quand on me
propose quelques jours je demande
toujours pourquoi on vient de chez
huawei
ouais je vous ai toujours sceptique
parce que je vois pas bien comprendre
c'est vous a quand même rapporter votre
troisième césar cette histoire mais oui
mais alors justement c'est un peut
intéresser des gens parce que maintenant
je tourne moins et je vends mes césar ça
s'est passé comment emmanuel vous aviez
le tract jouer avant avec ce héros comme
sa tête à tête non non non michel
esquisse moi j'ai non j'ai pas le trac
non c'était
enfin moi j'ai souvenir de si je pense à
michel et moi j'ai souvenir de deux
chaises qui se sont rapprochés petit à
petit comme ça ça a pris du temps c'est
pas immédiats on rentre pas dans
l'intimité des gens comme ça et mais on
a d'abord parce qu'on a fait un beau
film tron a été heureux ensemble qu'on a
eu de longues et belles discussions et
je me souvient michel quand tu m'a dit
un jour si celui là je le réussis j'en
prends pour dix ans c'est rien de sa wii
dont mais ce qu'il ya c'est que comme on
n'avait pas tellement non s'étaient
jamais rencontrés et je veux dire que la
complicité parce qu'on joue ensemble
depuis plusieurs fois au théâtre du
terrain c'est un apport c'est que mais
là la rencontre est aussi positive est à
dire qu'on se connaissait pas et en même
temps on joue la comédie et ont fait
connaissance avec les rôles et les
situations
eh bien ça colle alors michel serrault
vous vous êtes beaucoup moqué au début
de votre carrière avec jean poiret des
interviews à la télévision cela mettez
le début de votre carrière
donc vous allez payer ce soir on va
faire une interview nul
déjà
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle michel
serrault qu'est ce que tu veux est-ce
que vous préfériez hitler ou staline
je les ai pas aimé ni les uns ni visons
pas ce que j'ai préféré alex et zavatta
oui michel serrault vous devez partir
trois ans dans un vaisseau spatial
oui avec quelqu'un oui vous préféré
partir avec fabrice luchini edouard baer
ou josé garcia à cheikh jaber
ben pas vu parce que les enjeux les
connais je le connais bien je voudrais
beaucoup d'ennemis lui j'ai pas que je
reconnais aussi je vous intéresse edward
wright malgré l'intérêt des matières il
faut que je la personnage oui il faut
qu'ils ce modèle un peu qu'il ne met il
ya je pense que je peux lui dire encore
des choses les autres y sont et savent
ce qu'ils ont à faire
peut-être trop mais lui berne on peut
encore travailler beaucoup et c'est
l'ange blanc donc oui allez mignan
aignan cet ange blanc qu'elle amène des
des consommations non ça mon avis et des
paquets cadeaux pour l'unicef à ben ah
bon
est-ce que vous préféreriez michel
serrault faire l'amour avec une fille
très laide très laide ou un mec très
beau je me barre we had me barre
[Applaudissements]
jamais
attention le mot le plus con en amour
est-ce que c'est merci encore
ou oui oui non c'est ça va ah oui allez
c'est terrible ça chez coup mais bon ça
va je t'aime ça va hein
c'était terrible c'est con j'ai le
mettre dans vos questionnaires sahraouis
s'il vous plaît je toucherai la bombe
atomique arrive dans 5 minutes voient
enfin vous faites quoi quoi dans les
cinq minutes qui vous reste à vivre
je regarde ma montre jeudi j'ai plus de
4,3 avec qui passeriez-vous le plus
volontiers la nuit
anne sinclair lors sinclair ou brett
sinclair après la première
anne sinclair je la connais la série
fera plaisir
michel sait bien les enfants
il chante we will sont bien quand il
sent bien quand je suis son doux il m'a
là il s'en suit
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
c'est montbrial
la vidéo est simplement jeu j'adore ce
chien il doit elle a trois ans il est
bon comme toute l'équipe mais il ya une
chose qui m'a femmes se rendent pas
compte parce que dans ma femme dont je
parle même pas beaucoup je parle elle
tente pas trop élevé mais elles sont pas
très bien content parce que mais ça
c'est autre chose
moi quand je vois mon chien j'ai
l'impression de voir une personne est
alors il se dresse il a aussi grand que
moi il à la moustache comme non mais je
ne vous ça paraît rigolo comme ça
je vous dirai ce que tu veux manger
je veux dire le gain est ce que tu crois
que il peut devenir un humain je crois
qu'il faut faut arrêter des pétards
il faut arrêter de fumer la moquette
michel à cette élection à la région
normes lnh de faire attention
michel on est tous les deux oui on est
bloqué dans un chalet au tyrol
oui il a beaucoup neigé on peut pas
bouger du chalet oui on a rien à manger
ah je meurs de faim vous êtes obligé de
me manger vous commencez par quelles
parties de mon corps je commencerai
parce que ça me paraît elles sont assez
belle et importante
ce puissant te frappe pas mal mal mal je
vais te manger les oreilles aux mamelles
l'innocence
dubois manadou comme un agneau verse
péter appelant bachar l'oreille
oui c'est vrai qu'elle est à votre avis
michel serrault le sport le plus con
celui qu'on fait pas à si vous étiez en
vente dans un sex shop vous seriez quoi
je pense qu'ils vont de là dedans j'ai
la mémoire qui fait bien et très vite
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai n'accueille
pas tous à une petite enfance et sa wii
et toi tu irais je serai thierry
ardisson voilà vous avez glissé
sur le tour
romain soler mai
voici michel serrault
[Musique]
l'histoire
m
donnons-nous vise en effet c'est que
c'est trop ça mérite pas ça mais c'est
mérité si si un dragon à 6,6 comme elle
ouais ouais si si si si merci à la
commission zéro
franchement là la deuxième fois c'est
pas mérité non classé mais là il y en
avait autant pour toi et pour des
marques sur l'hommage ça tourne au
foutage de gueule moi je veux tu sais
comme je t'aime toi c'est bien
réciproque tête et bien c'est bien des
sols parce que oui à lui je suis pas
grand monde qui résistent surtout pas
beaucoup de comics comme c'est vrai rick
de comics qui trouve grâce à tes
vieilles halles a pas beaucoup en suis
pas dans l'évent pendant l'été dans les
dents les vivants non bien alors michel
serrault donc le fameux sondage du
journal du dimanche qui donne le
classement des français préférés des
français
oui vous a nommé premier comédien
préféré défense mais c'est quoi ça
car non seulement le succès du journal
du dimanche est sans doute dû à la mini
série de tf1 qui s'appelle la sphère de
mini çi meilleures audiences de tf1 en
2003 12,2 millions de téléspectateurs
50% de parts de marché alors ce qui est
intéressant
il y avait vraiment une osmose parfaite
entre entre vous michel serrault et le
personnage de gaston dominici
on vous a dit je pense qu'on avait
raison nous a dit vous ne jouez pas de
mine ity vous êtes 2 min tit b c la
vérité réussi dominici oui c'est moi
dominici je vais passer en jugement bien
pire il sera acquitté
ce qui est vrai c'est que souvent on
parle des méthodes de l'actor studio où
les gens pour tourner quelqu'un comme
gaston dominici vont tuer des anglais ou
en tous les cas s'immerger dans la
république dans la campagne et voir
comment on nourrit les poules et et vous
en fait michel vous avez fait appel à
des souvenirs personnels vous avez pas
fait de prénom d'une manière enfin d'une
façon générale quand même et je ne suis
pas non plus tu sais que j'ai tourné le
docteur potiez jamais mis de gonzesses
dont je vais pas de chaudières à la
maison oui c'est vrai enfin il ya un tas
de choses comme ça je ne suis pas non
plus dans garde à vue je vais pas
assassiner la petite fille c'est vrai
c'est vrai ce que vous dites quand même
et vous avez raison
point fort pour être comédien il faut
avoir la mémoire des autres peut-être
pas si oui non mais je crois que pour
jouer la comédie il faut prendre un
parti pris et je veux pas jouer dominici
podio sans avoir à mon avis là dessus
sinon j'ai rien à dire je me fais
remplacer alors là il ya beaucoup de
réflexions de cette qualité dans un
livre que michel serrault publie chez oh
éditions
qu'ils s'appellent les pieds dans le
plat tu l'as lu alors c'est un instinct
journal tenu de façon un petit peu
irrégulière parce qu'on n'a pas toujours
l'occasion de depuis deux mois
c'est un peu au gré des événements oui
d'ailleurs vous posons au peut changer
si on veut changer les dates pour lui la
réflexion n'est pas à huit jours alors
on va rester dans le métier d'acteur
si tu veux un si vous voulez pardon avec
un acteur qui s'appelle fabrice luchini
est un ami à moi oui vous dit fabrice
luchini m'agace qui vous agace c'est
fabrice luchini c'est qu'il a déclaré
reprend pour la première fois le rôle de
la musique de louis jouvet comme s'il
était un petit peu l'héritier de 2,2 ou
v2 son talent alors que vous vous
l'avais joué 300 fois la porte saint
martin ou trois ou quatre cent fois oui
donc ça vous choque un peu confiants
mais c'est parce que il est moi je les
aime beaucoup il a beaucoup de talent
mais ce n'est pas ce qu'on pourrait
croire il n'a peut-être pas assez de
mémoire
ouais tu comprends il en a dont jouit la
main pour jouer mais pour des incultes
et ta prestation tu veux dire ouais mais
facile mais c'est pas grave non si grave
enfin c'est en tout cas c'est rectifier
dans le livre ainsi rectifié puis
surtout ce que vous dites c'est que au
sujet de louis jouvet cette fois non
plus de fabrice luchini
c'est michel serrault écrit que louis
jouvet était un excellent et d'amandes
comédiens personne va remettre 100
ingénia mais dès qu'ils se mettaient
louis jouvet à faire des analyses sur le
théâtre ce que fait un petit peu luchini
c'était de l'esbroufé en fait cette
façon d'intellectualiser le théâtre ça
vous énerve quoi on parle de deux
ouverts qui était directeur de théâtre
il n'a jamais aussi bien joué la comédie
qu'au cinéma
ouais et alors il disait est ce parce
que s'il avait beaucoup de il avait
c'est génial
il n'entrait pas à dire le contraire
magnifique mais quand ont représenté
avec 1000 il avait horreur du cinéma ou
beck's que nous connaissons moi je vais
au théâtre plusieurs fois je les ai vus
deux fois dans ma vie c'était magnifique
aussi mais au cinéma
tout le monde connaît les prestations de
jouve est donc nommé lisais quand même
ça l'embêtait de d'admettre que le pool
à côté du théâtre il y avait le cinéma
où il était génial
alors voilà alors bon alors je parle de
ça parce que je
j'espère qu'un jour fabrice luchini
redescendra à ma portée parce que si je
pouvais jouer avec lui et qu'ils
m'écoutent
oui j'aimerais bien parce que le le
principal pour un acteur je crois la
première chose c'est comme ce que nous
faisons en ce moment tu me pose des
questions on y trouvera ses grands yeux
et les oreilles
es tu m'écoutes louis et moi j'essaie de
répondre oui et en diamant au théâtre
c'est pareil dit pardon qu'est ce que tu
dis je parle et tu me réponds vous
trouvez en gros que le king manque
d'humilité quoi c'est ça non je crois
qu'il a été mal élevés n'ont pu alors
michel serrault parle de fabrice guy et
puis à l'acteur qu'on ne peut pas nommer
par charité chrétienne ans il se prend
pour jean poiret qui limite
outrageusement premier pas deuxième
point ils jouent mal très mal même
troisième point mauvais esprits mauvaise
mine résume en quatrième point il donne
des leçons de morale à la terre entière
se dit humaniste mais n'oublie jamais
son intérêt personnel voilà dernier
point il est fait pour les tournées de
sous-préfecture où sa fausse élégance de
parvenus peut épater les casinos et
enfin il a un avis sur tout surtout dans
le sens du vent voix mais qu'il est
habillé pour l'hiver
je suis pas de qui vous parlez moi je
sais très bien de qui vous parlez
oui il nommait moi je pense avoir mais
je crois pas que ça puisse être lui
parce qu'il ya quand même des
contradictions
je vois que tu me dises à qui tu penses
il va
oui mais il ya des choses qui ne collent
pas du tout alors si c est lui et si
c'est lui et moi je pense michel pardon
je pense qu'il joue très bien la comédie
mais bon ouais c'est la seule chose où
là je veux dire la vérité les chefs
qu'on pense à pierre arditi en nous mais
on se dit que arditi joue vachement bien
la comédie donc encore dit non mais
c'est vrai quand tous les cas vous vous
êtes pas contrairement à ce que vous
dites de ce comédien vous n'êtes pas
dans le sens du vent vous êtes plutôt
n'est les pieds dans le plat c'est le
titre du bouquet à celles utilisées
justifie argentine par exemple vous ne
comprenez pas moi je trouve ça très bien
de s'attaquer comme ça aux vaches
sacrées vous ne comprenez pas très bien
pourquoi tout le monde adore jacques
tati mais c'est pas ça j'ai vu un film
ou deux elle s'était pas convaincant
dans la drôlerie
ouais il faudra mais là c'est mon nom
vous trouve ça chiant vous endormez
devant la télé et je dis la suite et la
suite après oui mais quand c'est positif
va pas non mais michel c'est vachement
bien que vous disiez ça moi je vous
savez je suis très bien où il ya une
espèce de consensus général national
c'est vachement bien qu'ils aient des
gens aiment et franchement victor hugo
c'est pas un peu de la merde écoute j'ai
pas lu alors la drire vous n'êtes pas
plus tendre avec les hommes politiques
en pas la même et il veut mais je n'y ai
dit tu es méchante fille alors apprendre
à faire un bout dit elle raffard à quoi
ou dit il et pas antipathique raffarin
monde a un peu l'impression vous dites
qu'il tient la boutique avant la
fermeture c'est vrai mais c'est vrai
c'est le comique quoi
mais mais c'est pas méchant quand on
parle des commis de l'état lui c'est le
co mais voilà il attend le patron alors
là où ça va pas non là où ça va très
bien justement section des services
publics
vous dites il faut que ça reste sous
l'autorité de l'état
je crois ça ce que je pensais à ça vaut
toujours dû me disais mais pourquoi n'y
aurait pas une armée privée aussi
bernard mira qu'on voit ce que ça
donnerait voilà c'est à dire la prison
d'abou ghraïb en irak
voilà alors vous parlez aussi des
intermittents du spectacle michel
serrault vous dit un truc vrai vous
dites les intermittents du spectacle
c'est une appellation épouvantable il
faut il devrait déjà manifestés pour on
les appelle différemment parce qu'un
intermittent du spectacle c'est vrai que
c'est un terme un peu un peu hard hausse
et alors effectivement vous dit les
choses parce que voilà vous dit
certains figurants de cinéma refuse de
tourner trois jours pour ne pas perdre
leur assedic
voilà là on en parle d'une chose très
délicate et devient difficile ce n'est
pas chose qui m'étonne toujours tu vois
tant mieux qu'on s'occupe de la culture
et qu'on donne la possibilité à tout le
monde mais km qui vient à lui mais une à
réchaud à gaz dans un film devient
intermittent du spectacle
là il ya un abus quelque part qu'est ce
que vous dites de 2 du peintre oui qu'il
était chez lui qui peint est quelqu'un
qui vend pas ses toiles
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire je demande ce
qu'il faut faire il ya il ya quand même
des critères et il ya des métiers à
risques j'ai eu mon pantalon troué
jusqu'à 25 ans tu comprends je veux des
jugements vous dites il faut accepter le
risque inévitable du métier d'artiste
savais que c'était un métier très sûrs
quoi c'est ce que me disent alors le
compositeur qui ne vend pas c'est que
c'est au qatar
qu'est ce qui va faire le poème alors
moi je voudrais aussi qu'on s'occupe de
lui
et puis on verrait les partitions puis
on essaierait de le faire manger aussi
est le compositeur et le peintre et le
et l'architecte qui y vend pas ses plans
etc etc
donc il ya une grande confusion là
dedans et que personne alors tout le
monde noie le poisson personnes 100 ans
je te gré des jeunes arrivent pas et
vivre ceux ci vivent cela pour un
minable
ouais ouais alors ceci étant michel
serrault vous êtes extrêmement
solidaires des victimes des injustices
vous dites suis-je de droite
suis-je de gauche oui effectivement à
l'église de droite je préfère l'église
de gauche mais votre véritable
dichotomie à vous elle s'opère entre
croyants et incroyants dans un premier
temps plutôt contre gauche et droite et
et vous dites il faut être du côté des
pauvres
voilà ça c'est la seule chose finalement
qui doit nous mener
occupons nous des gens qu'on rencontre
dans la vie on n'aura pas besoin de
s'expatrier très loin pour de mêmes
services
alors simplement ouvrons nos oreilles
nos yeux et puis ouvrons notre bourse
et puis essayons de faire quelque chose
mais le reich tous leurs achats manoir
et reste pas beaucoup
d'ailleurs vous dit un truc formidable
dit un athée solidaire vaut mieux qu'un
cadeau qui fait rien pour les autres
ben oui ça me paraît quand on ne sont
pas actionnaires et puis après ça bon on
ira peut-être vers autre chose mais ne
commençait pas par le bon dieu ne
parlait pas du bon dieu
il faut faire des actes si vous pouvez
aider quelqu'un à côté de chez vous ou
en lozère ou n'importe où voilà mais les
grandes idées n'ont commencé par sortir
des soutes votre poche pour les autres
je vous êtes un vrai chrétien vous je
suis pas un vrai chrétien je crois que
sans parler j'aime pas beaucoup qu'on
m'accuse d'être chrétien je suis pas un
exemple je suis pas mais je crois que
tout toutes les croyances commence par
l'espèce d'humanité de fraternité avec
les gens et basta le reste on verra
après
[Applaudissements]
alors
michel serrault il était aussi les pieds
dans le plat les pieds dans le plat un
pied dans le plat c'est le titre du
livre vous parlez de moi dans votre
bouquin n'ont pas de trace ici ça oblige
à vous vous dites thierry ardisson je le
préfère dans rive droite rive gauche que
dans tout le monde en parle
thierry ardisson c'est docteur jekyll et
mister hyde
c'est triste de le voir ainsi s'abîmer
vous parler de ce que je fais dans cette
émission c'est triste de le voir ainsi
s'abîmer c'est terrible ça que vous
disiez des choses comme ça michel je
suis le même dans les deux emissions
mais pour quelqu'un que j'ai c'est pas
terrible parce que j'allais y en a une
il ya 4 millions de gens et l'auto ya
deux cent mille personnes c'est tout on
peut pas faire la même chose vous qui
était un homme de spectacle c'est bien
qu'on peut pas faire la même chose pour
deux cent mille personnes ou pour 4
millions de gens et c'est ça qu'il faut
faire pour temps mais il y aurait jamais
calcio il faut vous qu'on gérait la
crainte pour faire comme ça à tous
publics mais c'est oui on essaye
noualhat et j'ai dit des choses aimables
quand même à vous dit à la fin de quoi
je me mêle de mieux en mieux
passe en écoulant je dirais que ce livre
il est fait pour rire sérieusement oui
et puis basta à l'oreille ce serait très
bien votre bouquin parce que juste après
m'avoir dit que j'étais docteur jekyll
et mister hyde
oui vous vous attaquez fogiel donc ça
c'est facile formidable j'attaque sur
brigitte bardot ah oui j'aime pas parce
que j'aime beaucoup brigitte bardot
ouais comme j'ai plus vingt ans j'ai
commencé avec elle à jouer la comédie et
je les aime beaucoup et je l'admirais
beaucoup comme comédienne comme
chanteuse comme femme magnifique
la belle est maintenant à l'euro s'amuse
et on fait du scandale autour d'elle les
animaux et qu'elle s'occupe des animaux
commencer
si vous n'avez pas le courage de de vous
occuper des autres
prenez exemple sur bardon et commencé de
dette bon avec les uns à mon avis et
vous verrez qu'un jour vous vous
intéresserez aux autres ou semaine aux
hommes aux femmes et aux enfants
donc alors basta pas de packs changement
rochelle ce que vous dites c'est qu'ils
l'ont manipulé pour l'amener sur le
plateau voilà avec une fois qu'elle a
été sur le plateau de l'ont massacré
voilà qu'est ce que vous essayez de
faire avec moi
comme ça
la première celle là ça c'est la
mastercard la minceur d'accord en dehors
des trois marques vous dites vous dites
encore des choses à vous dire plein de
trucs nord
vous dites vous dites que fogiel étaient
moins arrogant avec de longs parce que
delon l'aurait sûrement pas supporté bon
je pense qu'il ya de ça mais moi je dois
y aller chez lui mais je vais pas je
dois j'aime mieux venir ici parce que là
on se comprend
[Musique]
c'est bien
c'est pareil
alors comme vous avez dit que cette
émission était parfois nul mais vous
allez avoir droit
michel serrault à une interview nul
[Musique]
michel serrault vous devez partir
vous devez partir michel serrault je
dois parties devaient partir trois ans
ou alors tu me croisant dans un vaisseau
spatial avec quelqu'un vous êtes deux
dans ce vaisseau spatial vous devez
partir est ce que vous choisissez
thierry ardisson marc olivier fogiel ou
co et trois ans dans le vaisseau spatial
ben je crois que je t'emmène si gentille
non mais actuellement ils essaient de
deux points c'est un peu les gens pour
que cette soirée où cette émission est
un peu de piment et c'est normal est
anormal mais tu sais ce que tu as à tes
un bon fond sedrun c'est vrai tu n'es
pas méchant mais c'est bien qu'ils ont
quelquefois un peu bête mais
[Applaudissements]
michel est ce que vous préférez être
peint ces mordus ou pic et pic et je le
suis d'accord avec ce que vous
accepteriez d'échanger une paralysie
générale contre la fin définitive des
inondations au bangladesh paralysie
générale ont lancé lundi contre la faim
des inondations bangladesh en même temps
ben voui voui c'est intéressant je veux
sauver des vies 1 il faut que je
consulte un avocat tu seras paralysé
jusqu'à la fin de tes jours nous
faisions pas tous des jeunes écoutent
france me mentir pour l'eau aujourd'hui
un style jazzy je vais pas te répondrais
je comprends quand j'irai un peu moins
bien je te dirai allons-y
[Applaudissements]
si vous disparaissez émission zéro
acquis confieriez-vous votre enfant à
fabrice luchini ou à pierre arditi et
joué au couple il car ils font vraiment
beaucoup
vous avez commis un crime à qui demander
vous de cacher le corps aux gendarmes
avoir gendarmes et faux parents
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
michel la limace michel serrault est-ce
que vous préféreriez mourir tout de
suite là maintenant et aller au paradis
ou vivre trente ans de plus et aller en
enfer
je crois que je
la réalisation intéressante vas-y on est
tous les deux dans un chalet à la neige
en quelle horreur il fait pas toi
l'année
il fait très froid on te paraît sortir
du chalet on a pu en a mangé
oui vous êtes obligé de me manger vous
commencez par quelles parties de mon
corps fait pas que ça soit plus simple
sans vrai un peu de fond d'un bois
bien souvent des effectivement et vous
êtes encore plus bêtes n'ont donc que
vous préférez oui un président de la
république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout je pense que les il n'y a pas de
choix parce que c'est pareil
vous pouvez lire ou laisser faire les
choses
je pense qu'ils ont le même résultat
michel serrault 804 bon ça moi michel
serrault à nos rivaux avoir un nez
supplémentaires oui un oeil
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe et supplémentaires ont fait
embêté parce que je prends le sexe qui
verra après mais ça peut sinon non non
ce qui m'embête c'est avec son doigt l'a
carrément doigts dans le nez c'est pas
très joli comme une question quand même
il n'aurait pas fait ça avec toi là il
avait un col romain et c'était autre
chose maintenant avait de la tenue et
maintenant c'est la débandade
dernière question la plus importante
michel serrault oui vous laver les
cheveux tous les combien eh ben ça va tu
es tony près de deux fois par jour non
[Applaudissements]
c'est ans
nous y sommes
m
on est trois fois là ça m'étonnerait
trois fois penses tu allais pas la
maison l écrire à ma nouvelle loi ne
peut pas dire ou à l'est mais léo aller
chez un ami à elle n'était pas acquis et
tu la laisses aller si cette amie mais
elle fait ce qu'elle veut il ya
longtemps avant bah oui parce que tu
sais vous êtes un couple moderne
obama fait unis un vieux couple moderne
bon qu'est ce qu'il ya questions d info
puis hier ses vues non c'est pas
entasser lui ses côtés de gucci à thomas
vraiment effet plus avant il fait un peu
m
soit
pas de la main
c'est
[Applaudissements]
je reviendrai à
là on arrive à dire des bêtises comment
vous êtes un magnifique acté ah bon
[Musique]